جبهات تشكل اليوم دوامه دمويه مميته للجيش
الروسي والاوكراري فبينما تقدمت في الجنوب
وحققت انتصارات مهمه على عده جبهات تعاني
القوات الاوكرانيه على جبهه باخموت نظرا
لشده الهجوم الروسيه عليها المتمثل بتكثيف
القصفين المدفعي والصاروخي وبالمقابل يكون
الرد الاوكراني الدفاعي ايضا ثقيلا بقصف
مدفعي لا يتوقف للمواقع الروسيه وبالتالي
وقوع عدد كبيره من قتلى بين الجانبين
والمشافي مزدحمه بالجرحى لتبدو تلك الجبهه
وكانها مشهد من الحرب العالميه الاولى
وفقه وصف محللين عسكريين اصرار وموصفه على
انتزاعي باخموت ياتي نظرا لاهميتها كونها
تقع على طريق رئيسي يؤدي الى مدينتي سلوفي
والمدينتان ضمن من تقدم بس صناعيه التي لم
تسيطر عليها روسيا بالكامل بعد